Tenemos la proporción "x" menos 9 sobre 12
es igual a 2 sobre 3.
Y queremos encontrar el valor de "x"
que cumple con esta proporción.
Hay muchas maneras de hacer esto,
la mayoría de la gente
cuando ve una proporción como ésta,
se le ocurre hacer
la multiplicación cruzada,
3 por "x" menos 9
es igual a 12 por 2,
lo cual es correcto.
Déjame escribirlo por aquí.
Tenemos 3
por "x" menos 9
es igual a 2 por 12...
por 12.
Del lado izquierdo distribuyendo el 3
nos da 3 por "x"
menos 27
que es igual a 24,
ahora, sumamos 27 a ambos lados,
¿qué tenemos?
Déjame escribirlo, sumamos 27 del lado izquierdo
y sumamos 27 del lado derecho.
Del lado izquierdo se cancelan estos términos,
nos queda "3x" y del lado derecho
resulta 25 más 27
es 51,
ahora, dividiendo ambos
lados entre 3, "x" es igual a 17.
Así es que 17 menos 9 es 8,
8 sobre 12 es igual a 2 sobre 3,
nuestra respuesta es correcta.
Otra manera de hacer esto, en vez de hacer
la multiplicación cruzada sería eliminar
de entrada este 12 que tenemos aquí,
para lo cual multiplicamos
toda la ecuación por 12,
así es que multiplicando
por 12 ambos
lados,
aquí se cancelan los 12 del lado izquierdo
y nos queda tan solo "x" menos 9
y del lado derecho tenemos,
2/3 de 12,
2/3 de 12
es igual a 8,
podemos hacer de hecho
la multiplicación,
2/3 que multiplica a 12/1,
simplificamos aquí
12 y 3,
12 entre 3 es igual a 4,
3 entre 3
es igual a 1,
para terminar simplemente con
2 por 4 igual a 8
y ahora sumamos
9 a ambos lados,
eso es lo extraordinario
del álgebra,
no importa el camino que tomes,
mientras sea lógicamente consistente
vas a llegar al mismo resultado.
Y aquí de nueva cuenta
obtenemos "x" igual a 17.
Y también podrías multiplicar ambos lados
por 12 y ambos lados por 3
y va a ser equivalente a esta
multiplicación cruzada que hicimos.
Hagamos uno más.
Aquí tenemos otra proporción,
pero en esta ocasión
la "x" está en el denominador,
pero así como hicimos antes, si lo queremos podemos
hacer la multiplicación cruzada,
pero para que veamos
de donde sale esta multiplicación cruzada,
que no es algo mágico
que estás haciendo
sino que estás haciendo operaciones
válidas a ambos lados de la ecuación,
en realidad lo que estamos haciendo es multiplicar
ambos lados por ambos denominadores,
así es que tenemos este 8 aquí
en el denominador del lado izquierdo
y para eliminarlo,
tenemos que multiplicar
este término por 8.
Así es que multiplicamos
este término por 8,
pero para mantener
la igualdad de la ecuación,
también tenemos que multiplicar
por 8 el lado derecho.
De manera similar,
similarmente,
si queremos eliminar
este "x" más 1 de este denominador,
tenemos que multiplicar por "x" más 1
esta expresión, pero...
pero nuevamente
para que no se altere la igualdad
hay que multiplicar por "x" más 1
también del lado izquierdo.
Esto que hemos hecho es equivalente
a la multiplicación cruzada,
estos 8 se cancelan,
del lado derecho se cancelan
los "x" más 1,
por lo que ahora
queda del lado izquierdo,
"x" más 1 que multiplica a 7...
"x" más 1
que multiplica a 7,
el 7 lo voy a poner antes
para posteriormente distribuir
el producto y esto va a ser igual
al producto de 5 por 8...
por
8...
y observa, esto es lo que hubieras obtenido
de haber hecho la multiplicación cruzada,
la multiplicación cruzada es una manera rápida
de multiplicar una ecuación por ambos denominadores.
Tenemos que 7 por "x" más 1,
es igual a 5 por 8.
Y ahora, hacemos álgebra
para resolver la ecuación.
Del lado izquierdo distribuimos el 7
para obtener "7x" más 7 que es igual a 40,
ahora restamos 7 de ambos lados,
vamos a restar 7 del lado izquierdo
y 7 del lado derecho,
para obtener, del lado izquierdo
estos 7 se cancelan, nos queda "7x"
que es igual a 33,
dividimos entre 7 para despejar "x",
estos 7 se cancelan
y nos queda que "x"
es igual a 33/7,
lo cual podemos escribir como
4 enteros
5/7.
Y así hemos concluido.